(upbeat music playing)
(crowd cheering)
- So, I was talking to
Brian before we got here.
Y'all know each other.
You've known each other for, like, years.
- For years and years.
- Many, many.
And Robin, Brian's wife,
is one of my best friends,
and she was a bridesmaid at our wedding.
And we were at their wedding.
- [Brian] Yeah.
- [Kelly] And that's like,
over 30 years.
- That's a long time ago.
- A long time ago.
- That's like for us, it's almost 35.
And for you-
- 34, then. Yeah.
- Yeah. Exactly.
- Yeah.
- Just one year apart.
Oh my gosh.
So wait, have y'all ever had, like,
I mean in that time-
- I haven't seen him since.
(laughs) (crowd laughing)
- [Kelly] I imagine
you've had a game night,
or a dinner, or some kind of fun thing
y'all have done together, right?
- Well, we've had many fun
things that we've done together.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But there is
a really fun thing that we've done.
And, sometimes, we have
a dinner at our party,
at our house called "Sing
for Your Supper Party."
And we tell people that they have to come,
and they have to sing.
And you don't have to be a singer.
You can be anything in the business,
but you have to come,
you have to bring a song,
or you get no dinner.
And-
- What do you mean you
don't have to be a singer?
So they don't have to sing?
- No. Like if-
Let's say-
- Well, they have to sing.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- They have to sing.
But, you don't have to be
a professional to do it.
As a matter of fact-
- [Kelly] Oh.
- It's better if you're
not a professional.
- Oh my God.
This is like My Best Friend's Wedding,
when Cameron Diaz does
the karaoke. (laughs)
- It totally is like that. (laughs)
But you know, my pianist comes,
and he can play anything.
And people just show up with their songs.
And there have been many times that people
really impress you.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- In more ways than one.
(crowd laughing)
Yes.
- They dive deeper, or they really commit.
- Exactly. Exactly.
- [Kelly] Those are the people
I want at the dinner party.
- Totally.
- The ones that really commit.
- Yes.